newest marlin that is starling martay
there he is he's a two-time gold glover
and he fills and checks a lot of boxes
for the miami marlins one of the newest
members of the blue jays jonathan vr
outfitted in the new blue wearing number
30 playing short batting third tonight
in his blue jays debut and eliezer
hernandez is on the mound for the
marlins cavanaugh leads it off for the
blue jays as always
and he lines the ball into right field
for a base hit joyce will have to go to
the base of the fence to get it and
that's going to allow to allow bisho to
go into second base standing up blue
jays threatening with the runner at
third and now first at bat as a blue jay
for the pickup from miami jonathan vr
2-2 and he hits a bouncer to the right
side and biggio will come in to score
jonathan vr is a ball player he
understands the game kevin biggio
took third on the year by the pitcher
and immediately the blue jays have a
one-nothing lead and it's julian
merryweather to pitch for the jays so
that will bring up starling martay one
two swing and a miss she's a 98 mile an
hour fastball
arte couldn't climb the ladder there are
two away
first base runner
for the marlins
and see if they can do something with
that brian anderson coming up one two on
the way swing and a miss at a fastball
for the first down there's louis diaz
the first baseman
and a swing and a miss chased a fastball
a foot out of the zone but he got him to
go after it two down vigil who has been
a tremendous catalyst for this blue jays
lineup since moving into the leadoff
spot back on august 7th 2-0 pitch
division is down in ball three and now
time is called and a trainer
is heading out to check on eliezer
hernandez
liaison talking with the trainer and uh
it looks like eliezer
may be coming out of this ball game
he's walking off the field
so the marlins are going to be into the
bullpen early tonight eliezer hernandez
exits three games into the three pitches
into the top of the third and here is
robbie ray making his blue jays debut
and he'll face jorge alfaro leading off
the third blue jays one marlins nothing
and he got him swinging three pitches
and a strikeout the first battery faces
is a blue jay
birdie hitting ninth tonight
birdie slams one to center field and
deep back goes grichik way back at the
wall goodbye john bertie just got it out
of here over the w.b mason sign in right
center field and the marlins have tied
the game at one on john bertie's second
home run of the season the bases are
loaded with one out for derrick fisher
fly ball to left field got a little bit
of carry to it dickerson going back sets
up on the warning track
and teles can tag her to come home
fisher with a sac fly and the blue jays
take the lead
they're on top two to one
garrett cooper to lead things off swung
on lined into center field dropping
quickly and a dive by grichik in a great
catch randall grichik comes in
dives straight towards second base and
picks that ball off the blades of grass
a gorgeous catch to save a bay's hit
miguel rojas against robbie ray
and this one will test the gap in left
center field it'll get down and go to
the wall extra bases for miguel rojas
he's thinking about it and he will hold
up with a lead-off double
runner is going ray will step off and
they got him at third an 02 count he
takes off and robbie ray heard the
infielder say there he goes and he spun
around and makes a good throw to travis
shot runner will be on the move birdie
from first base with two down and a full
count
three two is lined to left field
guerrielle is there and then he comes to
the close bj's with a threat going here
two on and nobody out
they'll check on the runner at second
they pick off vlad jr from second base
and that's a big out here in the sixth
inning absolutely perfectly executed
josh and bertie watch him sneak back in
vlad even a little hesitation back
throws a dart to birdie birdie sneaks in
stealth you don't see pick-offs at
second base usually that way oh how
about this and then they turn it into a
6-4-3 double play and marte is aboard
now garrett cooper
and cooper hits one to right center
field hit well it's gonna one hop the
wall
marte on his way to third he will get
the green light and score garrett cooper
comes through we're tied at two in the
sixth
now john bertie been on base twice
john bertie
left that is out of the reach of the
left fielder guriel it rattles around
left field and birdie is going to get
into second with his second hit another
extra base hit a homer and a double
ground ball to the shortstop vr
and a nice pick over at first by tallest
as the side is retired jazz chisholm is
into the ball game making his major
league debut the 22 year old one of the
top prospects in the marlin system
and ranked as the best power hitter in
the marlin system after last season he's
into the game at short now it's a 2-2
game
and miggy's been hot and tested
immediately welcome to the big leagues
maybe starling marte comes through
oh maybe it's martay it's martay
it's definitely
a martay run in his first marlins game
and it gives him the lead in the eighth
inning welcome to south florida
well it's good to be a marlin
have yourself
a moment vlad guerrero jr
on a few hops anderson bare hands throws
and got him and lewin diaz able to get
in and get out of the way
of vlad guerrero jr before a huge
collision at the first base bag one out
wow
what a play by ba are you kidding me
and that is a backhand play at first
leigh when diaz will take it himself
it's a marlins win
3-2